Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Io sono un medico che,
tra i tanti privilegi,
ho avuto il privilegio
di stare negli Stati Uniti
quando hanno descritto
il primo caso di AIDS.
E questo per me è stato
una specie di imprinting
perché ha cambiato un po' la mia visione,
della medicina soprattutto.
E mi ha accompagnato
nella mia vita professionale.
Ma oggi vi parlerò, fondamentalmente,
di questo nuovo concetto,
cioè della salute globale.
E del fatto che esistono, nel mondo,
delle terribili diseguaglianze
in termini di accesso alla salute.
Ma partiamo dall'inizio.
Allora, questa diapositiva
vi fa vedere la curva straordinaria,
la crescita dell'aspettativa di vita
a partire dal '900.
Attenzione, queste sono medie:
c'è qualcuno che sta sopra
e qualcuno che sta sotto,
e ci sono anche
le differenze tra continenti.
Ma certo è stata
una crescita straordinaria.
E uno si dice: ma come
è successo tutto questo?
Beh, diciamo che il primo motivo vero,
quello dei primi, è l'acqua pulita.
L'acqua pulita ha cambiato la storia,
e la vita, e la salute di tante persone.
Quindi l'acqua pulita
è stata un determinante essenziale,
all'inizio, proprio all'inizio del '900,
quando è arrivata.
E poi, certo, i cambiamenti
socio-economici,
perché voi sapete che la salute
non è solo un fatto biomedico, no?
È legato anche al fatto
di dove uno vive, come mangia,
che lavoro fa: quello conta moltissimo.
Quindi sono migliorate queste condizioni,
quindi anche l'aspettativa
di vita è cresciuta.
E poi, certo, anche i progressi
della medicina,
che soprattutto negli ultimi tempi
hanno funzionato,
soprattutto nel comprimere
verso l'età più avanzata
le nostre patologie.
Qui c'è il buon vecchio Jenner,
anzi, il giovane Jenner,
che ha scoperto il vaccino.
Ci abbiamo messo 200 anni, a farlo fuori,
però insomma, comunque
i progressi ci sono stati.
Questi progressi non sono stati
equamente distribuiti:
ecco, questo è il problema.
È che tutte queste cose belle
non arrivano, non sono arrivate
a miliardi di persone.
La salute globale è una branca,
diciamo, della medicina
che si occupa proprio di lottare
contro le diseguaglianze
partendo dal fatto che ci sono
20 o 30 milioni di persone
che muoiono ogni anno per malattie
che sono prevenibili e curabili.
Quindi muoiono, non dico inutilmente,
ma insomma muoiono, purtroppo,
a causa delle diseguaglianze.
E si tratta di milioni,
miliardi di persone
che vivono in queste situazioni.
Che ce ne abbiamo sei, in totale:
ma almeno due miliardi vivono
sotto il livello che tutti ci aspettiamo.
Allora io prima di -
anzi, per aiutarvi a [capire]
il concetto di salute globale
vi voglio far vedere
che cosa non è la salute globale,
perché così lo capiamo meglio.
Allora, questo è un vecchio articolo
che avevo scritto nel 2000, figuriamoci,
in cui il concetto è questo:
che la salute non è uguale per tutti.
E guardate qualche diseguaglianza:
questa, per esempio,
è l'aspettativa di vita in buona salute,
perché non vogliamo vivere per sempre,
vogliamo vivere in buona salute.
Ecco, vedete quelle aree più chiare,
a parte qui l'Europa,
quanta gente ha un'aspettativa di vita -
in alcuni paesi raggiunge il 50%:
manco gli Etruschi stavano messi così!
E poi guardate questa:
questa fa veramente impressione,
questa è la mortalità materna, per parto.
In Africa, una donna su 20
muore di parto durante la sua vita.
Qui, quando succede
è il disastro, giustamente:
ma lì è normale, si muore di parto.
Vedete quanti paesi, quelli colorati,
hanno una mortalità materna intollerabile.
E poi la vaccinazione:
metà dei bambini del mondo
non sono vaccinati.
Stiamo parlando
della difterite, del tetano,
non stiamo parlando dei nuovi vaccini.
E poi, certo, la tubercolosi, la malaria,
l'AIDS, di cui parlerò
un pochettino, dopo:
be', certo, queste qui stanno sempre lì,
stanno piazzate in quei paesi lì.
E guardate questa, che è interessante:
questa è la mortalità prematura
per le malattie croniche.
Cioè il diabete, l'ipertensione,
quelle che abbiamo qui,
nei nostri lidi ricchi, diciamo.
Ma vedete dove muoiono?
Le zone rosse, più scure, è dove si muore.
"Ma lì non ce ne avevano di meno?"
"Sì, ma lì si muore".
È quello che ho detto l'altro giorno
a questo mio amico.
Gli dico: "Se mi piglia
un piccolo infarto qui sul palco,
probabilmente qualcuno mi raccoglie,
e mi porta a Como,
dove mi stappano una coronaria.
Quando vado in Africa?
A volte me lo domando e dico: "Certo
se mi piglia l'infarto qui, ci rimango".
E questa è la diseguaglianza:
che lì non hanno accesso
ai servizi e alle cure che abbiamo qua.
E attenzione, non si tratta
soltanto del sud del mondo.
Perché molti dicono:
"Beh sì, son quei poveri",
no, guardate: questo è
il trenino di [Giuseppe] Costa.
Geppo Costa è un grande
epidemiologo di Torino,
che ha studiato la popolazione
di Torino negli anni.
E se uno segue il percorso del tram,
dalle colline ricche
fino alla zona operaia,
si perdono sei anni
di aspettativa di vita.
E queste diseguaglianze sono a Torino!
E non parliamo delle diseguaglianze
nell'aspettativa di vita
che abbiamo tra nord e sud Italia.
E uno dice: "Ma qual è il motivo
di tutte queste disuguaglianze?"
Be', certo, un po',
bisogna dire la verità,
è la globalizzazione
un po' selvaggia che c'è stata.
Perché non c'è dubbio,
che la salute sia legata alla povertà.
I poveri muoiono di più,
e [si] ammalano di più, per tanti motivi.
Ed effettivamente, la globalizzazione
ha portato pure un po' di crescita,
ma in modo terribilmente disuguale:
l'1% della popolazione mondiale
ha praticamente tutto in mano.
E non c'è dubbio
che questa selvaggia globalizzazione
[abbia] peggiorato, anche,
la salute delle persone:
vedete, questi sono i ricchi,
questi sono i poveri.
E fondamentalmente, tra l'altro,
e di questo si occupa la salute globale,
noi ci occupiamo soprattutto
dei più marginalizzati,
quindi a partire dai poveri -
questo è un homeless -
ma [anche] i carcerati!
Pensate che cos'è la salute,
dentro le carceri di tutti i paesi.
In alcuni, tra l'altro,
è una cosa devastante:
E poi, anche, le donne che lavorano,
i lavoratori del sesso, come si dice,
ma [anche] i tossicodipendenti,
che sono marginalizzati
perché incarcerati.
E poi le persone che vivono negli slum.
Voi sapete che c'è un miliardo e mezzo
di persone che vive negli slum:
vi rendete conto di cosa può essere
la condizione di salute là dentro.
E poi tutte le persone
che si sono dovute spostare:
non stiamo parlando soltanto dei migranti,
ma anche di quelli
che hanno dovuto cambiare paese.
E quindi, queste sono le persone
che stanno peggio.
E poi le donne: perché le donne,
vedete questa diapositiva,
in alcuni paesi del Sudafrica
il 50% delle donne giovani
sono sieropositive.
Certo non è perché al virus dell'HIV
piacciano di più le donne giovani:
è semplicemente che queste donne
non hanno gli strumenti culturali,
e di potere, per proteggersi.
Adesso abbiamo parlato di AIDS,
e ve ne parlo un attimo,
perché in realtà è un po' stata
la passione della mia vita,
ci ho lavorato tanti anni.
E c'è una cosa positiva,
stavolta, che vi voglio dire,
perché noi l'AIDS lo usiamo un po'
come modello
per combattere le diseguaglianze.
La storia è lunghissima,
ma ve la racconto in tre minuti.
Allora, un virus un giorno
passò da una scimmia all'uomo,
erano gli anni '20.
Poi si è fatto un gran giro
per il mondo, ma rapidamente,
soprattutto a partire degli anni '50,
è andato in giro.
Non c'è paese che non abbia casi di AIDS.
Quante persone sono morte di AIDS, finora?
In pochi anni, dall'80,
quando è stato più o meno descritto
nei paesi occidentali,
40 milioni di persone sono morte.
E altri 40 vivono, oggi,
con questa malattia.
A un certo punto,
negli anni '80, e io ero là,
l'AIDS è diventata
la prima causa di morte dei giovani.
Ci ha messo un attimo, e boom!
La prima causa di mortalità dei giovani.
E vedete,
vi ricordate quanti attori,
quanti personaggi famosi,
morivano di AIDS?
Questo è Rock Hudson,
poco prima di morire.
Poi è successa una cosa straordinaria:
abbiamo, collettivamente,
messo a punto una terapia.
Era il '96, quindi ci abbiamo messo un po'
però questa terapia ha fatto una cosa
che a me mette i brividi.
Quando vedo questa diapositiva,
ancora mi vengono i brividi,
perché come medico,
avendo visto tutti i miei pazienti
morire uno dietro l'altro,
quando è arrivata questa terapia;
vedete la curva rossa?
Questa è il declino
della mortalità per AIDS.
Diciamo che da un certo punto
non si moriva più di AIDS.
Be', è stata una cosa
che per un medico è fantastica.
Ora, questa cosa,
e vedete, non sono solo i numeri,
questa è una bambina
che stava lì, morendo.
E dopo sei mesi è la stessa bambina.
Allora, questa cosa
è avvenuta nei paesi ricchi,
che si potevano permettere
di pagare questi farmaci costosi.
E nell'anno 2000
la situazione invece era questa:
vedete la curva rossa?
Sono i morti per AIDS in Africa.
E quella blu sono i morti da noi:
vedete com'è bassina?
Perché appunto non si moriva quasi più.
E allora io -
vedete anche l'impatto
che aveva questo sull'aspettativa di vita?
Alcuni paesi africani hanno perso
30 anni di aspettativa di vita,
a causa dell'AIDS.
Io ho avuto, anche,
un altro grande privilegio,
che nel 2000 mi hanno eletto presidente
di questa "Società Mondiale dell'AIDS".
E a un certo punto mi è venuta un'idea:
perché non portiamo la grande conferenza,
roba da 20.000 persone, in Africa?
Mi dicevano: impossibile!
Mi hanno criticato aspramente:
non verrà nessuno, hanno paura di starci.
È invece è stata un successo clamoroso,
perché sono venuti in migliaia,
sono venuti i giornalisti, 1.300,
e poi c'era lui,
questo era un uomo di un certo livello.
E naturalmente la storia cambiò.
È cambiata perché da lì, da Durban,
è cominciata la grande battaglia
per l'accesso alle medicine, alle cure.
Che è continuata: l'anno dopo
è stato creato il Fondo Globale,
che come sapete porta i soldi
dei paesi ricchi ai paesi poveri
per sconfiggere non solo
la tubercolosi e la malaria,
ma anche l'AIDS.
E effettivamente, vedete oggi
che abbiamo 20 milioni
di persone, nel mondo,
che prendono i farmaci antiretrovirali.
Ecco: questo già vi fa capire
perché l'AIDS è da considerare un modello
per combattere
le diseguaglianze di salute.
Non solo, poi, perché ha messo insieme
un sacco di gente diversa:
gli scienziati, Kofi Annan,
ma anche le chiese e gli economisti,
con l'obiettivo di sconfiggere
una malattia globale,
la prima malattia globale della storia.
Quella che avevamo visto qui
e stava anche giù.
E poi ha fatto abbattere
il costo, il prezzo, dei farmaci.
Questa è stata una battaglia -
adesso, detta così, sembra semplice,
ma il fatto di riuscire a portare
i farmaci generici
in tutta l'Africa,
in tutto il sud del mondo,
è stata una battaglia pazzesca.
Ma è successo.
E questa è un'altra
diapositiva fantastica.
Questo è l'impatto:
quella curva della mortalità
sta andando giù pure in Africa,
e stanno risalendo le aspettative di vita.
Vedete come, portando i farmaci dal 2000,
ecco che stanno risalendo
le aspettative di vita di quei paesi.
Quindi l'impatto c'è.
Va bene, non è finita la storia dell'AIDS:
lui ancora gira, ci vorrà una cura,
ci vorrà un vaccino.
Però è stato fatto tanto,
è stato un modello che noi prendiamo
per parlare di salute globale.
Ora questo, che cos'è questa bestia qui?
Questo è Ebola.
Vi faccio vedere questo
soltanto pr spiegare
che in un mondo veramente
così globale, così interconnesso,
con fenomeni migratori
di portata epocale, con gli aerei,
come possiamo pensare
di risolvere i problemi di salute
solo a casa nostra?
Come possiamo non pensare
che occuparsi della salute
di tutte le persone
che vivono su questa terra
non sia anche promuovere la salute
dei nostri figli,
delle prossime generazioni?
Quindi, questo è il concetto
della salute globale.
Oggi abbiamo degli obiettivi straordinari
che sono stati firmati
da tutti i paesi della Terra.
Poi vediamo se ci arriviamo,
però sono 17 grandi obiettivi,
dalla lotta alla povertà,
alla fame, all'ambiente.
E il numero tre di questi obiettivi
è quello della salute.
Questo obiettivo della salute ci dice
che noi dovremmo andare
verso la copertura sanitaria universale,
cioè il fatto che tutti
gli abitanti della Terra
abbiano accesso alle medicine
e ai servizi sanitari primari.
Per quel motivo che dicevo prima,
perché in un mondo così globale
è impossibile non pensare alla salute
come qualcosa di universale e globale.
Ora, questo è un bellissimo obiettivo.
È un po' un'utopia,
però ci stiamo andando.
Per questo,
quello che è stato fatto per l'AIDS
noi lo consideriamo
una specie di piccolo modellino
di sforzo collettivo
verso la salute di tutti.
Ecco, questo è un faro:
un faro che, come sapete,
può essere usato da qualsiasi navigante
per raggiungere il porto.
Ecco, questo qui si chiama bene pubblico.
Questo è un bene pubblico:
come l'aria che respiriamo,
come l'acqua dei fiumi, i parchi.
Sono cose che tutti possono usare,
chiunque può usare.
E usandole, non le sottrae ad altri.
Questo è il concetto
di bene comune e di bene pubblico.
E noi pensiamo che la salute,
e l'accesso ai farmaci,
debbano essere considerati,
dovranno essere considerati
come dei beni pubblici
a cui tutti possono accedere,
indipendentemente dalla ricchezza
del paese in cui si trovano.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)